hey 42 here as we speak
you are being swindled this year
corporations will hide roughly 500
to 600 billion us dollars in corporate
tax revenue
through legal and illegal means
respectively known as tax avoidance
and evasion american fortune 500
companies alone
are estimated to be sneaking away 2.6
trillion taxable dollars
in cozy little islands and or states
with flexible taxation laws
but that's just big companies you say
everyone knows they do that
what about your bug standard rich people
this video is not about the minefield
that is corporate tax avoidance
but personal wealth how do the
millionaires and billionaires of the
world
pay little to no tax on their hefty
salaries
and multi-million bonuses well
good old-fashioned rich people have
stashed away 8.7
trillion dollars according to
conservative estimates
more comprehensive estimates stack it up
at around 36
trillion dollars that's right 36
trillion dollars in other words the cost
of jeff bezos new bathroom refurb
although it's popular to do so i'm not
going to point fingers at the uber
wealthy
and scream about how naughty they are
for hiding untaxed income
because it's easy to look at these
statistics through envious eyes and
proclaim
why should we live in a world where
governments allow this to happen
but truthfully the situation isn't so
black and white
at the end of the day you can't have
international free markets
without enabling the conditions for tax
loopholes to exist and free market
capitalism
is the greatest system ever devised by
mankind
it has lifted billions out of poverty
and no it isn't perfect but it's the
best we've got
to close every single legal loophole and
stop all tax avoidance governments would
have to become
a lot bigger and more authoritarian
and i for one i'm not a fan of that
but yes i hear you there are certainly
downsides for the average joe to this
morally dubious and highly secretive
side of free market capitalism
there is a hell of a lot of money
slipping through the tax man's fingers
each year
money that could be used to improve
infrastructure
healthcare education and funding nasa's
awesome space explorations
for my lovely american viewers this is
what we english like to refer to as
being
mugged off the american translation
being a phrase
youtube won't allow me to utter the
reason these numbers can vary is that
well
squirreling money away requires sneak
100 you don't want to get caught and so
by engaging in the practice
you need to employ a hell of a lot of
secrecy
and discretion that makes you difficult
to track
these practices can also sometimes be
difficult to define
tax havens for instance are a favored
strategy of the rich and wealthy
for protecting their money from the tax
man however
what actually is a tax haven although
there are
various definitions in essence it's a
location
either offshore of across a border where
you can hide your money
whether you're dodging tricky
regulations or trying to avoid criminal
liabilities
these will likely be your go-to choice
and as the billions and trillions of
dollars i detailed earlier
show they're a go-to choice for a lot of
people
who it turns out will go to some
shocking glimpse to maintain their
privacy
in april 2016 a whistleblower by the
alias
john doe my that's an original one
leaked 11.5
million documents to the worldwide press
all of which detailed financial
information for over 200 000
offshore companies who had dealings with
panamanian offshore service provider
mossack fonseca when analyzed
the document showed that countless
individuals and companies
had used offshore business entities to
commit fraud evade tax
and even dodge international sanctions
the document showed that major banks
had helped to drive the creation of
well-hidden companies
and that 140 politicians and public
officials around the world
all used panama to hide their money
politicians including the king of saudi
arabia
the prime minister of iceland the prime
minister of australia
and even some no doubt well-intentioned
childhood friends of juan vladimir putin
some of the implications were so severe
that john doe refused to reveal himself
as his life was in danger he only cited
that
income inequality was his motivation
behind the leak
and of his decision to release the
documents he said i understood enough
about their contents to realize the
scale
of the injustices they described in
short
he noticed you were getting mugged off
and like the decent guy he is he thought
he'd let you know
the leak helped to bring the tax
avoidance slash
evasion strategies of the rich to public
knowledge
as well as the depth of financial
corruption that existed in
certain governments the papers for
instance
brought to light numerous fake companies
owned by top
maltese officials which were being used
to conceal
wealth but as i said a few moments ago
the wealthy involved wanted these
secrets kept and
the reporter who helped bring these fake
companies to light
was killed in a car bomb
but look i get it inequality only sucks
when you're not in on the action being
the
proactive ambitious and mammon
worshiping fortitude viewer i know you
are you're not one for protest or
complaining
you want to know how the rich do it so
you can start taking
your own slice of that big morally
unscrupulous
800 billion dollar tax dodging
pie well you've come to the right place
there are dozens of techniques to rich
use for hiding their money
and astonishingly none of them are
technically illegal they're just clever
financial practices
based on national and international laws
that were in no way put in place by the
same wealthy elites that leverages them
wink wink now before we go any further
and this should probably
be fairly obvious but none of what i'm
about to discuss
constitutes actual financial advice and
you should probably ignore all of it
so let's say you've suddenly found
yourself 300 million dollars richer
naturally your first step would be to
grow a glorified yet dignified mustache
like mine but
after that what would you do with all
that money and how would you scribble it
away from the praying guys of the
government
one option would be to buy an
unnecessarily enormous
super yacht by decking your absurd boat
out like a house
and spending as little as two weeks per
year on it
you can pretend for tax purposes that
it's a second home
you can then rent it out for two weeks
per year
and you won't have to declare the rent
as income
and if your new maritime home
appreciates in value
you can claim it as capital gains and
have it taxed
at a lower rate capital gains
essentially being where an asset you own
rises in value before you sell it most
common with
sought after assets that last for
decades
such as properties and 42 merchandise
genius right and alongside all those tax
benefits you also get an enormous
environmentally unsound monster yacht
that you can staff with
the look jewish supermodels and watch my
videos on
not quite feeling a supermodel laden
yacht well
you could haves all your money within a
corporate entity
which would mean for legal reasons your
money would be in a lower tax brackets
than it would if it was stored
in your pocket this means you can pay
yourself out of your corporation
and if you're creative enough of
expenses and
how you earn your money you can
significantly reduce
the tax you pay mitt romney for instance
supposedly claimed his management fee
for his own company as capital gains
i'll let you wrap your head around that
one the irs is still attempting to
another way you could do it is to use
something called a deferred compensation
scheme
this is dull corporate language that
basically means you'll get paid your
full salary
at a later date so even though you earn
the exact same amount of money
or more you get taxed less considering
the amount you'll be paid will be
hundreds of millions who's sweating
about a 10-year waiting period
it's no wonder 79 of fortune 500 ceos
are offered deferred payment plans you
can also do something as simple as just
swap things around with other people to
dodge tax
sounds stupid right it's called an
equity swap
and it is kind of stupid an equity swap
allows you to trade the gains and losses
on assets
without actually transferring ownership
which
in turn allows you to dodge irritating
niggles like
transaction costs or even local taxes
another strategy
would be to take up stock options by
putting a huge amount of your money into
stock options
your money is only taxed when you choose
to cash out your options
this allows you to choose when and how
much tax you will pay
at any given time this is the financial
equivalent of building up a bar
tab with the government but these are
all no more than
tricks to save a few million bob here
and there
let's get down to the real meat and
bones of how you can hide your enormous
wealth from the government
and what is that exactly offshore
accounts
and shell companies let's start with
offshore accounts which i spoke about at
the start of this video
as the panama papers showed offshore
accounts are extremely attractive to the
rich and powerful
and there also conveniently completely
legal
so long as your government doesn't think
you're using them to hide illegal funds
or fund illegal activities offshore
accounts are perhaps
deliberately mind-bogglingly complex
this is one of the main reasons why
they're so useful if you're trying to
hide money
if you aren't a tax professional you
have little hope of understanding what's
happening
and where the money is going this is no
doubt why when the panama paper scandal
was exposed
countless rich and powerful figures
simply held up their hands
offered a bemidji smile and said hey i
just signed some paper
i had no idea what it all meant but
so you can profit from the same blissful
ignorance i'll simplify it for you
as much as possible offshore accounts
are based in tax havens
which are countries with little to no
taxes that offer complete financial
discretion
sounds good now here's how you do it
let's say you want to protect your 300
million dollars
the first thing you want to do is set up
an offshore account in a tax haven
sometimes this will require you to have
citizenship
there but as your pockets are literally
leaking
dollar bills this shouldn't be an issue
just stuff some of them into the palm of
the nearest corrupt official
and what do you know you're a newborn
panamanian
swallowing around in white linen shirts
and a straw hat
but setting up an offshore account isn't
enough
you want secrecy you don't want anyone
to know
it's you who owns this offshore account
after all many regions such as the us
the eu
and russia will slap you with hefty
penalties and legal charges
if they spot your making income from a
foreign account
so what you need to do is set up a
limited company or
trust in your tax haven with a nominee
stockholder
or rather stooge who appears on public
documents
as the owner whilst you sit margaritas
on the beach
operating behind the scenes as an
unexposed beneficial owner
enjoying your tax dodged income as the
internet will tell you this is exactly
what the illuminati does with the united
states
to access your money you can set
yourself up as a contractor for the
company
wire your millions over to it and then
take it out as multiple loans or one
loan to yourself
alternatively if you don't need it right
now you can start using it within the
company
to invest and grow your money to make
further
tax dodged millions genius right
well that's a step further because if
you really want to hide your money
and everything you've bought with it
such as private jets and luxury houses
then you're going to want an intricate
array of shell companies
that is meaningless fake companies
that exist around the world to disguise
what it is you're actually doing with
your money
shell companies exist only on paper and
typically have
no office and no employees but can be
used for
a variety of means from money laundering
to tax evasion
to serving as a vehicle for business
transactions
despite possessing nothing to actually
trade
let's take an example with your millions
you buy a private jet
something the tax man likes to
obliterate with vat
being the 42 subscribe tax dodger that
you are
you already own a company in a tax haven
we'll call this
mustache incorporated using mustache
incorporated
you will purchase the private jet and
then
import it to another company you've
created
which then leases it to an agent
who then allows you to use your plane
but here's the thing if your offshore
companies are based in a
notoriously tax-lenient isle of man
this allows your private jets
value-added tax
to be completely refunded a figure which
can be as high as 20 percent of the
value of the aircraft itself
so now you can fly around the world in
your mustache emblazoned plane without
paying a penny
in v80 for your extravagantly luxury
item and all you had to do was create a
string of meaningless
pointless businesses moriarty himself
would be in awe
although as is often the case with these
things the conditions surrounding this
legal loophole
seems downright petty according to the
international consortium of
investigative journalists
f1 star lewis hamilton treated himself
to a brand new
27 million luxury private jet
but with the help of the legal
wranglings of a law firm in bermuda
he received his eye-watering vat refund
of 5.2 million dollars
the legal condition was that for his new
plane's inaugural flight
it had to first touch down in the isle
of man
and stay there for no less than two
hours
as long as tax havens that allow for
complete financial secrecy
exist these sorts of financial practices
will continue and luckily for you new
tax havens continue to emerge
the u.s state of south dakota for
instance shields your money from the
government
ex-spouses business partners income tax
inheritance tax and capital gains tax
it's no wonder that assets held in south
dakota
trusts have swollen from 50 billion
to over 300 billion over the last decade
a fact which has no doubt made south
dakota's famous mount rushmore residents
turn in their graves so if you've got
millions
don't pay your share of tax like anyone
else hide it away and enjoy it
and if people start snitching on you
consider blowing them away with a car
bomb
as michael corleone like to say it's not
personal
it's strictly business thanks for
watching
you can now pre-order my new book stick
a flag in it on amazon
link in the description thank you